حسنا هناك كلمات أخرى هناك غيرها
مواضيع أكثر أهمية مثل
التنمر المدرسي على سبيل المثال السنة
آخر هناك الكثير من الأطفال
الذي انتحر بسبب هذا و
بصراحة لا يوجد أي إجراء لديه
تم اتخاذها على أنها أداء
الطلاب وما إلى ذلك
[موسيقى]
إنه فستان طويل وفضفاض إلى حد ما.
سأقول إنها عملية طويلة ولكن
في حد ذاته أعني أنه رأي
عادي لا يوجد لا يوجد
العلامات الدينية المميزة أعلاه ط
أعتقد أن اليوم السابق بما فيه الكفاية لا يوجد
علامة دينية فيها أعني
يبدو الأمر كما لو كنت ترتدي فستانًا
[موسيقى]
لأننا نعلم أنه سيكون هناك بعض
بالإهمال ربما ولكن في النهاية
الكثير لمحاولة تحدي
النظام الجمهوري يجب أن نكون واحدا
علاج
[موسيقى]
وإنشاء لجنة من
tarism إذن فهو جنون لأنه في
تفعله الحكومة في كل مرة
الكلمة الكبيرة هي القتال ضد
الكوميدية يفعلون فقط ما لا يفعلونه
تضخيم السعر فقط